this is pretty cuny
so grandpa stayed here overnight
and taka came down here first
and they don't speak the same language
but somehow
my dad
needed to give taika a milk
which i think is cuny
their bond is awesome makes me so happy
yeah it's crazy because i was like dad
how did you know he wanted milk like did
you because that's one thing i was
always been like
not scared but like um
like wary of
i'm like i can't leave them too alone
because they're not able to communicate
but
they somehow figured out which is cuny
and awesome
so we brought out the heater and tycho's
been doing the heater decks show them to
heat it down
why does it make you dance like that
build water
didn't go to grandpa yeah
how cuny is this so this is normal right
we're in the morning
i train with mama
mama's getting ready to train
and then we also have taika
but how often is grandpa also here i
feel like a little audience
and we all
get to hang out here and get fitness
together this is cuny huh
you killed me
two
[Music]
that's my favorite
you give a kiss good job duty it's my
favorite
you should have one too
okay
what you're just passing on hugs and
kisses all day
cute there's so much love today
hey tucker have you seen this place
before no
never
eating uh
oh that's under the sign
wahoos
fish
tacos
it's funny
because we see this place all the time
because taika's jiu jitsu is right there
let's see if i can find it not you can't
see the sign but taika jiu jitsu is
right across the street
and so my dad doesn't know um how to get
to the freeway so we drove on the
freeway so my dad could follow us to get
to the freeway
and uh
on our way back we're like you want to
just try to eat wahoo's fish tacos
because we never really eat here we see
it all the time so now we're here
show me all the skateboards how many
skateboards are there
that's awesome
you know what you're gonna eat mama
potato
i ate here back in college there was one
in our uh on our campus yeah oh i want
churro chips though
for the groms
kids
you know it's pretty funny i don't think
i ever walked out of a restaurant before
but i was looking at the menu and since
we're back on the diet i was like none
of these things seem appetizing there's
a lot of bomb food a lot of cheese and
stuff but i can't eat those and the
things that i can eat i'm like uh i
don't know what about you mama well i
think for me this is business 101 yeah
too many options everything's all over
the place uh it needs to be a little bit
more condensed and i was just
overwhelmed by this by like all these
choices and none of it really made sense
i was like
that's like what are you getting i'm
just gonna copy off of you because
there have been so many studies done on
if you have too many options people just
get overwhelmed and they walk away so
lesson that's true keep it simple stupid
that's like that's business 101 k iss
honestly that exists
in business so keep it simple stupid
until next time wahoos and i'm not
on a diet i've seen a lot of cheese a
lot of enchilada stuff and guacamole i'm
gonna get but not today
so this is pretty cool we found this
place on yelp it's called the protein
source and what i like about this place
is that they have the macronutrients on
the menu so like for example steak and
egg skillet right tells you 760 calories
67 protein 37 carbs 38 grams of fat and
they have that for everything from
pancakes
to wraps
to
other kinds of bowls and salads and
stuff so it actually looks pretty good
i'm really hungry i think i might get a
pancake too to be honest
especially if they know what it is let
me get the chocolate fever
get a steak and egg skillet no i mean
or you get french toast with
nine grain whole wheat bread
[Music]
cool twin towers
[Music]
you know what you're gonna get mama no
clue i was kind of dreading i'm like i
hope it doesn't tell me what i'm like
again we have a million [ __ ] choices
uh you want a breakfast item or a lunch
item
lunch because they have all these bowls
you get a steak lover skinny salmon
teriyaki chicken mark and mussel
no help
so what did you get over here no clue
the one i originally wanted uh had like
apple and kale i think it was greens and
like cucumber and stuff
um and they were out of apples this one
sounds better though so on the fly i
went this one and this one didn't have
apples but it had like coconut water
pineapple those two are alone are one of
my favorite combinations pineapple i
could tell i could tell by your order
that it's your favorite well this one is
called peanut butter lovers
and it has chocolate protein in there
and two types of peanut butter and it
has 50 grams of protein so and this meal
this plus the other uh thing that i
ordered
it's 60 grams of protein so i'm gonna
have 100 grams of protein one meal
what was that good
uh it's very natural and raw so no added
sugar
really
this is also the first time i've ever
gotten a uh
vegan protein
oh they asked me you want whey or v or
veggie and i was like oh i've never
tried veggie broth give me a veggie one
so i'm about to see how it is and i got
it with almond milk so the whole thing
is technically vegan
even though my uh meal is steak and eggs
shut up seriously shut
it's peanut butter protein
you can drink this every day but you get
chopped
50 grams of protein a little bit
imagine he was like
oh [ __ ]
i don't think that's
hey
you can't do that
okay
this actually looks pretty high quality
and taika likes the protein shake
which as a proud bro father
i like very much
that turkey bowl looks really good too
let me try
is it pretty good
we might have found our new healthy
place
maybe no it's not i just bit it i know
it's not hot big
all right so papa took taika to jiu
jitsu and get ready to catch me winded
in three
two
one i always get so winded
after coming up these damn stairs
oh okay
but anyway um so now it's my time
to go
into the abyss
into the abyss
that i
call an office that i refused
for so long to tackle because as we all
know
it's not about the rearranging
it's not about the rearranging of the
big furniture that's the [ __ ] that's
the fun stuff
we all know
that the shitty [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
happens
when you have all the little knickknacks
that you're like trying to find a home
for like
all the little
pens
and note cards
and staples
and refills on ink cartridges and and
rulers
and all that stuff you know what i mean
the big stuff is fun because you're like
you know but the little stuff you're
like
so
i have no other excuses now
i've organized everything else i've even
organized the storage underneath our
stairs i've organized all of tyka's
stuff i've run out of things to keep me
preoccupied
to avoid coming in this room
and here we are
i gotta do it i gotta take advantage of
this hour that papa's gonna actually an
hour and a half
that papa's gonna have taika so
i gotta get it done i got to get it done
so here we go
so tell me about your day
how have you been you've been good
i hope you've been good
you deserve to feel good
all right all right i'm avoiding it
you're right okay moving on
okay two hours later
and no sweater on we have
some junk
but i want to show you i didn't get to
organize the way i wanted to but at
least i moved things out of the way
i wanted to show you everything
don't come in yet pop on a show then
first you see it behind me
so this is what i mean but i wasn't able
to
organize it the way i want to but at
least
things
are not
on the floor anymore
oh
i have a space again
i did it
okay how much about now okay come on in
yep
turn off the lights
yes please
yep yes
turn on the lights
where the light doesn't work yeah i'll
find it
there it is
beautiful thanks baby wow the mfc yo
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa yeah so as
you can see like i was saying i didn't
get to organize the way i wanted so
there's a bunch of little knick-knack
pedi wax over the place and they're all
[ __ ] up yeah baby
make me a lot of money
this is also not straight up i know i
don't care i'm gonna help you fix it
later okay that's not important that's
what i'm talking about these little
things
the point was to get space oh you got
space
looks great and i even moved the boards
out of your your closet monkey you're
gonna break my keyboard cut it out
that's awesome
two hours
two hours yeah it took me two hours to
do all this
remember all these boxes that were here
and it was just a cluster of things
leave it no no no that's not yours all
right
good job dude
i highly highly highly recommend tell my
parents out there to get your kids
started cleaning up their own mess as
soon as possible i'm fortunate enough
that i had my mom
teach me that when tyke was so young so
as soon as he could start walking my mom
would sing the song what what what song
would grandma sing every time it was
clean up time
[Music]
yeah so she would sing that to him so
every time she would start singing that
song
he would know that it's clean up time so
we clean up all the time another thing
that we started doing because they are
going to start talking back
some of them some of them are really
good
not that this guy is bad but he just
always has an opinion about stuff so we
started doing because we started being
not talking back but just being careless
with this stuff we were like okay cool
dude clean up and for every toy that we
find that's out of place you're gonna do
a push-up and how many push-ups have you
done so far every time you miss uh
cleaning up
40. no you don't do any push-ups because
you always clean
yeah i want to
sleep with tonight okay you'll sleep
with him tonight but yeah so that's a
good little come here
right here
oh
um okay so
good job so yeah so those are some
little things that you can do i don't
like incentivizing for chores like i
don't like going if you do your xyz
chore then i'll give you a dollar if you
do this then i'll give you because then
they start equating it with like rewards
where it's not a reward it's their
responsibility so i really
try hard to not do that um hey
are you playing are you cleaning i'm a
doctor
i'll give them that because i was really
creative but clean dude that means
you're playing and not cleaning we gotta
go to sleep and on that note thank you
guys so much oh damn
okay bart
alright see you guys tomorrow bye